- Hi, I'm Meaghan from Khan Academy,
and in this video, we'll
walk through the reports
related to assignments on Khan Academy.
After you've created
assignments on Khan Academy,
and your students have
completed those assignments,
you can track progress
using a variety of reports
designed to help teachers
gain a deeper understanding
of student's strengths
and areas for opportunity.
Start by selecting the class
from the teacher dashboard.
And then selecting scores
under the assignments tab
in the left-side navigation.
This will bring you to the
assignment scores report.
In this report, you will see progress
across assignments for
all students in the class.
If the assignment is a video or article,
and students have
completed the assignment,
you will see a green check mark.
To earn completion for a video,
the student most have watched
at least 90% of the video
at no faster than double speed.
To earn completion for an article,
the student must have
clicked into the article.
If the assignment is an
exercise, quiz, or test,
the student's best score will
be shown in a color-coded box.
Boxes appear as red for scores 0-59,
yellow for scores 60-99, or
green for a score of 100.
If the student has not
completed the assignment,
the box will remain gray.
To access a more detailed report
for an individual assignment,
from the assignment scores report,
select the assignment
name for any assignment
that contains questions.
This includes exercises,
quizzes, and tests.
This screen shows you an example
of an assignments responses report
for an exercise that
contained seven questions.
On the left side, you can
select the first or last attempt
students made to answer the question.
You are also able to select each question
to see students' responses.
If you've chosen to provide
different questions for each student,
the questions appear in the order
students found them most challenging.
The questions students incorrectly
most frequently appears at the top,
while the questions
students answered correctly
most frequently appears at the bottom.
If you've chosen to provide
the same question for all students,
the questions appear in the order
in which they were presented to students.
On the right side, you can
select a specific student,
or the whole class, to view the
assignment responses report.
Select the responses tab on the right
to see a summary of student responses.
Correct responses can be highlighted
by selecting the reveal answer button.
You can view which
students gave which answers
by selecting an individual response
to display student names.
Many teachers recommend
keeping students' names private
when sharing this report
with the entire class.
You can select the draw tab
to reveal a scratchpad space
that you can use to solve the
problem live with students.
Many teachers recommend using a projector
for the class to follow along.
Some teachers also
suggest having a student
solve the problem step
by step for the class,
instead of the teacher,
as a way to encourage
student voice and build
student confidence.
In the hints tab, you can view
the step-by-step process
to solve the problem.
These are the same steps
provided to students in real time
when they select the "get a
hint" option in an exercise.
You can also access the
assignment responses report
by selecting the manage tab
from the class dashboard,
and then selecting view report
for the individual assignment.
The assignment scores report,
and the assignment responses report,
are helpful in monitoring assignment
progress for an entire class.
If you'd like to look more closely
at the assignment progress
for a single student,
use the individual
student assignment report.
From the class dashboard,
select activity overview
from the left-side navigation.
Then select the individual student
whose assignment progress you want to view
by selecting the student's
name from the class list.
This brings you to the
individual student report.
Select the assignments tab to view
all assignments given to that student.
This report displays
the due date and time,
assignment name, assignment status,
attempts made on the assignment,
and the student's best score
if the assignment is an
exercise, quiz, or test.
There is also a red indicator that appears
next to the assignment status
if the assignment is late,
meaning the student
completed the assignment
after the due date.
The individual student assignment report
can also be reached from the
assignment scores report.
From the assignment scores report,
select the student's name
from the student list
in the assignment scores report.
This will bring you to the student's
individual student assignment report.
We hope this video helps
you better understand
the assignment reports on Khan Academy,
and how to best use these reports
to support student success.